[موسيقى]
الضلع اذا كان الاصطناعي لقينا انه
الموضوع عنصر مساعد انا بدخله مثلا احنا
رسمينها فبيديني
افكار كتير جدا اقدر عليها واطورها واطلع
منها بفكره جديده ما اتعملتش قبل كده
فعملنا في الاول اللي هي اللي نزلت واللي
الناس شافتها عشان كل مكان فكره الملكات
وازاي كانوا بيلبسوا فكل دريس هتلاقيه
باسم ملك جينا بعد كده فكرنا ان احنا
داخلين على سيزون الصيف فلازم الملابس
تبقى
ابسط شويه ومناسبه للصيف البحر الكاجوال
الحضاره المصريه جريئه او لها حضور فازاي
اخلي بيعبر عن نفسه بالحضور ده بشوف حاجه
جوه هي دي بالظبط اللي تقول انا مصري بس
الحاجه دي لازم تكون لان احنا في عصر حديث
والناس ابتدت تسال والسوشيال ميديا في
تفاعل جامد قوي فنانين ابتدوا يسالوا
مذيعات ابتدوا يسالوا لا في حركه جامده
احنا عملنا اول عرض ازياء عملناه في
الميتافيرس تاني عرض عملته كله كاننا عند
معبد حتشبوت لكن طبعا زي اي براند ناويين
ان احنا نعمل عرض ازياء كبير ويكون في
مكان تاريخي بيعبر عن نفس المحتوى بتاع
الفشل
[موسيقى]
قبل ما ندخل على الاي اي احنا بنعمل كذا
ورك شوب واحده للتاريخ واحده للفاشن واحده
اختيار الخامات واحده الاسكاتشز بعدهم
بندخل
مش هياخد دورنا الفكره لازم تطلع من هيوم
يعني تطلع من بني ادم
[موسيقى]